strong and athletic solid as an x model
sporty as a coupe the new bmw x6 eludes
categorization and does well in every
driving situation
its powerful bmw twin power turbo
engines combine dynamism and efficiency
and the bmw xdrive puts this power on
the road a car that guarantees a grand
performance
the xxx
car tester reinhold eisenhofer says with
the x6 bmw invented a new class of
vehicle the suv coupe this big crossover
polarized automotive fans from the start
some find it too brawny and swaggering
precisely what others like bmw has sold
more than 260 000 x6s around the world
since
mile
2008
broad muscular dynamic its front
expresses resolution mighty air intakes
and at the power behind them the broad
rear where horizontal lines massively
underscore how solidly it's planted on
the ground adds to the dynamic
impression the bmw x6 aims to burst all
bounds and national boundaries it's
built in spartanburg south carolina usa
well what we have right behind us is
actually where we have the bmw body and
the bmw powertrain coming together in
what we call the marriage line here at
plant spartanburg here's where we call
it the car's getting its first initial
heartbeat and it's pumped ready to rock
on to the customer and finish up the
production process
the bmw factory in spartanburg began
producing cars for the world market in
1994. more than 2.5 million vehicles
have meanwhile been manufactured here
and the new bmw x6 is slated to start
rolling out the production line in
december the bmw efficient dynamics
motor family combines the newest fuel
injection technologies highly variable
power control and innovative turbo
charging technology making the x6 a
statement about power and performance
and yet it's moderate in fuel
consumption and emissions its engine
comes in two gasoline and two diesel
variants these engines range in power
from 190 to 330 kilowatts
kreinholtz says it makes a strong
impression when you pull your new x6 up
in front of the office restaurant or
theater but the x6 is also impressive
off-road terrain that used to demand a
range rover is now open to this suv
coupe
the m-performance twin power turbo array
6-cylinder diesel engine in the bmw x6
m50d sets a new benchmark for combining
striking dynamics with astonishing
efficiency the advanced engine responds
extremely quickly
even at low rpms the engine has a lot of
torque and the revs range is especially
broad
typically for bmw the cockpit is
tailored to the driver clear arrangement
and top-notch craftsmanship are
convincing
the eight-speed steptronic sport
transmission adapts to the driver's
individual driving style ranging from
comfortable cruising to highly dynamic
sportiness all at the press of a button
with a steptronic transmission shifting
is extremely comfortable and as
efficient as possible
what we do is we have the associate who
takes his lift assist
and he comes to the rack and actually
has to pick up the ip
and the lift assist just helps him hold
the ip
and guide it to the car
they have to tighten their screws down
and then you have the associate in the
middle who finishes the process by you
know routing their electronic wires and
then they end up installing the radio
and the face plate on top of that
the standard bmw x6 chassis sets
standards bmw xdrive guarantees
outstanding traction on any surface and
any weather x-drive and the dynamic
stability control or dsc keep it driving
stably and on track
the intelligent all-wheel x drive
instantly distributes power to both
axles so the car touches the road
optimally thus the x drive combines the
advantages of all-wheel drive traction
stable handling and driving safety with
the agility typical of a bmw we are
loading the tires here we have the tires
come around just in time the tires will
come around the front tires first we'll
load it if it has a 2v8 option then
we'll load up a locking lug if not we'll
just put in five regular lugs and we
will go from there then the rear tire
come around we'll load it start those
and then torque them down with the
multi-spindle
in the bmw x6 m50d the engine the
chassis technology and the design work
seamlessly together with impressive
dynamics comfort and practicality
the new x6 is more angular than its
predecessor the chassis is a benchmark
the equipment blameless the x6 may look
more compact but it's still a powerful
4.9 meters long and weighs a good two
tons
the bmw x6 is built to move in germany
the price for this kind of mobility
begins at 66 150 euros if you like think
sporty the bmw x6 m50d is a good choice
that the volvo v60 plug-in hybrid has a
range of 50 kilometers so the driver
should recharge the battery at every
opportunity fortunately it has the
necessary cable in the trunk
he says this end plugs into the car
and the other goes into the outlet
sounds simple
but the cable is fitted with a special
plug
if it isn't compatible all the driver
can do is get out a cable reel and hope
for the best
but this particular volvo v60 plug-in
hybrid is already fully charged so the
test drive can begin when driving on its
diesel engine it puts out 208 kilowatts
with fuel consumption rated at 1.8
liters
running on electric power it can cover
50 kilometers free of emissions running
on both it can go 900 kilometers without
refueling it accelerates from zero to
100 kilometers per hour in 6.1 seconds
just sitting in it matas can hardly tell
any difference between the plug-in
hybrid and a standard v60 except that
the combination instrument cluster
includes a battery level indicator
alongside the fuel gauge and an
indicator for whether the car is running
on electricity or diesel
hybrid and power drive modes the power
mode as the name implies relies more on
the diesel engine giving the car more
power
with diesel farad
and if he needs to go easy on the
battery the safe button switches to the
diesel for long drives cross country or
on the highway and saves the battery
power for the stop and go driving
typical of the city
it's hard to tell any difference between
the plug-in hybrid and a standard v60
from the outside as well
the sporty look of the five-door station
wagon is brought out even more by the r
design dynamic attributes
chromed emblems identify the plug-in
hybrid as such
the trunk offers just 304 liters of
volume partly because of the space taken
by the recharging cable stowed under a
panel inside
the hybrid diesel's interior has been
kept in the traditional volvo style a
digital instrument cluster is standard
in the v60 d6awd
matas had to get used to the power
steering since the diesel engine doesn't
run continuously the steering isn't
hydraulic powered assisted as in the
standard v60 instead it's electric and
that has a different feel which takes a
few kilometers to adjust to
what's his overall impression after the
first few kilometers
mata says unfortunately the volvo v60
plug-in hybrid isn't as fuel-efficient
as the 1.8 liters per hundred kilometers
the car maker claims for it his average
of about 6.2 liters is far removed so
for a good 10 000 euros less he could
buy a standard v60 with the biggest
diesel engine in germany it consumes
about the same and has a bigger trunk
the second generation of the
mercedes-benz b-class will be hitting
showroom floors across europe in late
november over 380 000 units have been
sold worldwide since it was launched in
2011.
both interior and exterior have been
revamped a broad radiator shield and
daytime running lights integrated into
the headlights give the new b-class a
more dynamic look
electric drive and natural gas drive are
available
these days the automotive industry is
all about saving fuel and limiting
emissions porsche is no exception
putting out an se hybrid version of its
best-selling cayenne with consumption
rated at 3.4 liters per hundred
kilometers the plug-in can cover 36
kilometers at up to 125 kilometers per
hour on electric power alone the 82 000
euro list price in germany is almost two
thousand euros more than the cayenne s
this light green 224 kilowatt ford focus
rs belongs to dennis
he swears by it
when the ford focus came out in 2009 it
set new performance standards for front
wheel sports cars
especially in traction and handling it's
a compact class vehicle with a racing
car feel
our car tester dennis insect says this
car is awesome but now he's looking for
something more family friendly but he
doesn't want to compromise on sportiness
the sea at leon cooper 280 aspires to
the best of both worlds it's seatt's
speediest compact model
copious air intakes point to a powerful
engine under the hood
leon's trademark rear design as well as
the two tailpipes add to its dynamic
look
so dennis says it doesn't appear that
sporty at first glance
he likes the look of the headlights
and notes the wide tires
he notices the rear end is narrower
the exhaust and matching diffuser lended
a degree of sportiness dennis is excited
so
time to go for a spin
you can sense the cooper's sporting
lineage right away cooper stands for cup
racing a modified cooperative is among
the fastest front-wheel drives ever to
take the nurburgring's legendary
nordschleifer track
a limited slip differential improves
on-road performance the cooper offers a
range of driving modes
as far as dennis is concerned the modes
are only good to play around with
once you've chosen one you're likely to
stick with it the rest are mostly
designed for people who like to mess
around with buttons
our test car courtesy of dsg is equipped
with gear shift paddles
dennis says this car's shift pedals are
a bit small and you need rather long
fingers to keep your hands on the wheel
while changing gears he prefers shifting
manually which makes driving more fun
the two-round instruments and
three-spoke steering wheel with embossed
logo give the cooper's interior a sports
car feel as do the seats
dennis thinks the cockpit design is
visually appealing and uncluttered
despite being a little heavy on plastic
so how does driving the cupra compare to
the focus rs
dennis says the engine can't quite
compete but concedes that it falls only
marginally short on performance and
sportiness
a top speed of 250 kilometers an hour is
pretty standard for a car like the cupra
it moves from zero to 100 kilometers an
hour in 5.7 seconds its 206 kilowatts of
power is almost 20 less than dennis's
focus puts out
theoretically it should perform better
on the road
dennis says the cooper's traction is a
little worse when accelerating out of
curves than his ford has
he's got plenty of material to form an
impression of the leon time now for his
verdict
it's sporty he decides but it's not a
real alternative to the ford
a vinyl roof
abundant chrome trim
the finest leather and wood inlays it
must be a luxury car from the early
1970s
the jaguar xj coupet with its v12 engine
is quintessentially english blending
elegance and sportiness into one
at the 1973 london motor show the
british luxury brand rolled out a
four-seat coupe version of the xj it
launched five years before
the series familiar straight six engine
was standard with a v12 as a glorious
option
since it was made in very small
production runs the noble cat is rarely
seen on the open road these days or even
at vintage car meets
11 dealership appreciates the sleek
lines of the older car and the
12-cylinder engine's interaction with
the automatic transmission he says it's
nothing like the conventional power
trains of the time but he can hardly put
it in words
jaguar's 5.3 liter v12 was a legend
among car engines famous for its even
acceleration and silky smooth running
but among mechanics the car was more
infamous
he says the engine compartment looks
more like a snake pit he's got no
problem with the engine itself
it can run dependently for some 200 000
kilometers without an overhaul but he
doesn't like disassembling the entire
intake duct just to fix the air
conditioning maintenance is very time
consuming even if parts are relatively
easy to find but otherwise he says the
car is nothing to fear
jaguar unveiled the xj coupe in 1973
but it didn't appear in showrooms until
two years later it targeted the
individualists who could dispense with
four doors in favor of two but not with
the luxury of the jaguar sedan it was
based on
describes it as a car for the
connoisseur capable of high speeds
though without matching aerodynamic
design the grill is a bit small for his
taste but he likes the way this jag
glides along at 160 kilometers per hour
has no b-pillar so driving on country
highways with the windows down as
heavenly
the imitation leather vinyl roof is
typical of the 1970s
and having two fuel tank filler necks
near the rear windshield is typical of
jaguar
aside from the rear doors the coupe has
all the amenities of the sedan among
them a large trunk for that holiday on
the french riviera and space for four
people
the interior offers the obligatory
luxury ambience with fine wood paneling
around the dash and british connelly
leather on the doors and seats
in the mid 1970s an xj12 coupe cost the
equivalent of about 25 000 euros making
it jaguar's most expensive model
says it was a top car for a top price at
the time it cost about the same as a
small townhouse like plunking down 200
000 euros for a car today just as far
beyond the reach of ordinary mortals now
as it was then
we're not thinking not so much
parts are available for the xj but it
may take some intensive searching to
find a 12-cylinder coupe a in good
condition and it could easily cost the
same twenty five thousand euros it did
new
yen
explains that prices for the xj coupe
are climbing and they're much higher
than for a sedan from the time
very few specimens are left the body the
last to be designed by sir william lyons
and the powertrain are quite unique all
this makes for a car's attraction
the launch of the new generation jaguar
coupe
the 2x2 xjs in 1975 spelled the demise
of the xj coupe a
but hardcore jaguar connoisseurs insist
that xjs can't measure up to the
elegance of xj coupe
one of the most alluring automotive
creations of the seventies
you